c'est une espèce invasive qui gagne du
terrain
le scarabée japonais son appétit
redoutable cause de plus en plus de
dommages en agriculture pour s'en
débarrasser il existe différentes
méthodes
il ya peut-être une lueur d'espoir à
l'horizon depuis quelques années on
observe le scarabée japonais qui s'est
installée au départ c'était vraiment
mignon parce que c'est un joli petit
insecte est très beau couleur bronze il
ya des jolis reflets il a l'air
sympathique il est moins sympathique
quand ils se multiplient à la vitesse
grand v et qu' il envahit et qui mange
tout début juillet dans une bleue est
fière de dunham
en estrie les fruits ne sont pas encore
mûrs que déjà les scarabées japonais qui
viennent d'émerger du sol ont commencé à
faire des dégâts
ils vont d'un plan à l'autre ils se
baladent et puis grignote un peu partout
et c'est ça qui est dommageable en fait
c'est que il abîme beaucoup et que nous
étant ouvert à l'autocueillette ça
représente quand même plus de la moitié
de notre récolte c'est l'auto cueillette
on veut que ce soit attrayant pour nos
clients
sept espèces exotiques envahissantes
active surtout en juillet et en août
l'entomologiste jacques brodeur la
connais bien dans son lieu d'origine le
scarabée japonais est pas con c'est
comme une espèce nuisible parce que tout
un cortège de nimy naturel que ce soit
les champignons des bactéries des virus
des prédateurs des parasites qui
contrôle de façon naturelle dans son
environnement
les populations de scarabées japonais
malheureusement les scarabées japonais
est arrivé ici en amérique
seuls 5 son cortège d'ennemis naturels
donc là il peut proliférer sans attaquer
par tous ses ennemis naturels
c'est en 1916 qu'il est introduit
accidentellement aux états unis dans
l'état du new tunes y très bien adapté
aux hivers froids
l'insecte remonte tranquillement vers le
nord il est répertorié pour la première
fois au pays
en 1929 dans le sud de l'ontario depuis
il ne cesse de gagner du terrain
le scarabée japonais peut faire des
ravages à différents stades de sa vie sa
larve est l'un des fameux ver blanc qui
infestent les pelouse et une fois adulte
le coléoptère qui mesure à peine 2 cm
peut s'attaquer à 300 espèces de plantes
différentes
[Musique]
très grégaire les scarabées peuvent
grignoter jusqu'à ce que les feuilles se
transforme en squelette
les dommages sont souvent
impressionnants mais tue rarement les
arbres au québec
suite à son introduction s'est surtout
concentré sur des graminées à gaz ont
donc déclenché quelque peu d'importance
économique
donc tant les agriculteurs que les
chercheurs prêté peu d'attention
l'insecte même s'ils étaient présents et
depuis quelques années avec l'expansion
de production d'hydro-québec peine on
s'aperçoit également que le scarabée
japonais attaquent également certaines
cultures maraîchères beaucoup les petits
fruits et là ça devient un problème
économique pour s'en débarrasser
certains insecticides sont efficaces en
colombie britannique les premiers
scarabée japonais ont été signalés il y
à peine deux heures dans un secteur bien
précis de vancouver dans cette zone
aujourd'hui réglementées on pulvérise
pour tuer les larves au printemps et
tenté à tout prix d'éradiquer l'espèce
[Musique]
à ce jour au canada seule
terre-neuve-et-labrador et les trois
provinces des prairies sont jugés
exemple de scarabées dans l'est du pays
l'insecte est déjà trop répandue pour
espérer l'éradiquer chimiquement claire
viard pedneault dont la bleuette hier
est en régie biologique a choisi pour sa
part d'éviter d'utiliser des
insecticides
on est capable de vivre avec un petit
pourcentage de nuisibles comme on les
appelle je n'aime pas beaucoup ce terme
là mais c'est le terme utilisé
on en sait d'une partie à la nature la
nature nous donne généreusement dansait
d'une partie comme pour les oiseaux
aussi nous rendre beaucoup de services
mais si la proportion est déséquilibré
la sadc le gagne-pain où on a envie donc
on peut pas se permettre de ne rien
faire de rester les bras croisés on
cherche des solutions partout parmi les
solutions mises à l'essai il y a les
friches des espaces aménagés où on
retrouve des plantes qui plaisent aux
scarabées
mais les friches ne suffisent pas pour
tenir les scarabées loin des plants de
bleuets
voilà pourquoi des pièges ont fait leur
apparition sur la colline sont encore en
partenariat avec agriculture et
agroalimentaire canada jacques brodeur
mène ici un projet de recherche avec
l'autre ses étudiants au plus fort de la
saison ses pièges munis de phéromones et
d'odeurs floral peuvent attirer des
milliers de scarabées par jour mais il
des doutes dans la littérature il ya une
ambiguïté qui existe depuis des
décennies sur l'utilisation du cash à
savoir si on peut l'utiliser pour piéger
en masse l'insecte il ya certaines
études qui ont démontré qu'au contraire
le piège attire beaucoup plus d'un
siècle ce qu'on veut piéger donc en
quelque sorte on va attirer les masses
et des masses d'insectes dans les
cultures et c'est justement ce avoir un
effet négatif sur la production
il ya d'autres études au contraire qui
disent que oui le piège est super
efficace parce qu'on veut piéger des
milliers des milliers d'individus dans
une culture et les uns du concierge bien
évidemment se retrouve pas sur les
plantes qu'on cultive pour mesurer les
impacts du dispositif des feuilles
située à différentes distances d'un
piège seront récoltés tout au long de
l'été on va prendre cinq feuilles
pleinement développée et on va regarder
c est ce que du dommage est ensuite
quantifier ce dommage là en les
attachant et en mesurant à l'aide fin
leaf mi-temps donc une quelque chose qui
mesurent la surface des feuilles donc
avec son de votre mesure de quantifier
les dommages est basé sa sur la distance
avec le piège
les chercheurs mesureront également la
présence de larves dans le sol autour
des pièges et là où elles vont
s'attaquer aux racines
donc c'est un mal qui est beaucoup plus
discret à voir mais qui avec le temps va
avoir des risques beaucoup plus grand et
plus c'est la contrôler plus celle
observée au clair viard péno ce projet
de recherche arrive à point nommé
surtout qu'elle constate que les
scarabées ne se contente plus de manger
les feuilles
il ya deux ans juste du feuillage
l'été dernier là on a commencé à
observer des dommages sur les fruits et
cette année on n'est même pas ouvert
encore et là déjà
les dommages sont apparents c'est pour
ça qu'on est inquiet parce qu'on les
trouve très agressif et c'est un
comportement nouveau mais il ya une
lueur d'espoir pour contrôler le
scarabée une mouche parasitoïdes aussi
originaire du japon
introduite aux états unis en 1922 pour
contrer le scarabée elle progresse avec
lui vers le nord est a été observé au
canada pour la première fois il y a une
dizaine d'années on peut facilement
détecter sa présence grâce à ceux-ci un
ou plusieurs points blancs sur la
carapace de scarabée sell-off pondu par
la mouche est collé au thorax des
femelles pendant l'accouplement
c'est le seul moment on sait pas
pourquoi où le parasite arrive à pondre
son oeuf sur la femelle jamais le
parasite arrive à pondre son oeuvre sur
une femelle qui est seul qui est en
panne seulement en tête même s'il est
immobile ça prend un accouplement pour
qu'à une pente
de cet oeuf sortira une larve qui
viendra forer un trou dans la carapace
de scarabée et dévoré l'insecte de
l'intérieur parce que ce sont les femen
surtout qu'ils sont pas restés là ça
n'impacte doublement important sur la
diminution des populations de scarabées
parce que ce sont les femelles qui se
reproduit ce sont les femelles qui
pondent des zouk donc le parasite est
génial parce qu'il dit c'est le sexe qui
le plus important à contrôler
mais cette mouche peut-elle vraiment
faire la différence dans la lutte contre
les scarabées
nous sommes au jardin botanique de
montréal un lieu qui n'est pas épargné
par les scarabées japonais la roseraie
et l'un de leurs endroits de
prédilection
plusieurs fois par semaine des pièges
doivent être vidés au jardin botanique
les premiers scarabée parasiter ont été
aperçus en 2017
l'entomologiste marie-eve gagnon s'est
alors demandé à quel point cette mouche
était répandu aux collègues du triple
saut scarabée japonais mais on sait pas
c'est la mouche parasite se retrouvent
au même endroit dans lequel la
distribution de ce parasite et au québec
pour répondre à cette question la
dizaine de pièges installés par ses
collaborateurs dans la province ne lui
suffisait pas elle s'est donc tournée
vers les réseaux sociaux
on a fait un post facebook qu'ils
faisaient
appel aux citoyens de dire si vous voyez
un térabit japonais avec un petit point
blanc
prenez la photo puis envoyez nous les
aux services de renseignement otomo
logique à l'insectarium juste comme ça
puis là j'ai eu des centaines et des
centaines de réponses l'appui ça leur
fait une belle banque de données grâce
aux 317 photos envoyées par des citoyens
la carte de la distribution de la mouche
s'est grandement précisé on était
étonnés de voir que oui ce qu'avait dit
car les japonais il y avait le parrain
states parce que le pasteur et dont le
vus a pas si longtemps que ça donc pour
quelque chose qui est arrivé
naturellement que ça soit distribué la
même manière que son hôte
c'était assez étonnant oui l'année
dernière le taux de parasitisme au
jardin atteignait dans certains cas 40%
des résultats encourageants mais ce qui
limite le contrôle qu'exerce le
parasitoïdes c'est le manque de
synchronisme
contrairement à ce qui se passe au japon
ici la mouche émergent avant le scarabée
et elle disparaît au mois d'août alors
que le scarabée peut se reproduire
pendant encore plusieurs semaines et
pour la mouche les pièges ne sont
peut-être pas une bonne nouvelle étant
donné qu'on cage à la fois le scarabée
et son paradis et que les indiens vont
mourir dans le piège évidemment une
certaine proportion de la population de
parasites qu'on va où situer avec le
piégeage
mais on espère que dans la nature ya un
niveau de près 6 quand même conséquent
qui veut s'établir dans les populations
qui ne sont pas piéger
à terme les chercheurs souhaiterait
pouvoir élever cette mouche sur laquelle
on sait encore trop peu de choses
notre espoir on a cette fameuse petite
mouche l'autre piste ce serait de
réussir à trouver une plante pour
laquelle il ne puisse pas résisté qu'il
adore littéralement et qu'il laisse
tranquille morneau au plan bleu ou plus
largement les la production fruitière
qu'en outre la mouche une guêpe a aussi
été introduites du japon pour contrer le
scarabée cette gamme s'attaque aux
larves dans le sol mais sont tout succès
est moins élevé que celui de la mouche